in unserer letzten episode i st -germain
hat eine junge dame aus den usa
folgenden satz gesagt nicht so viel als
in den usa sagen ja die junge dame
wollte sagen in den usa gibt es nicht so
viel trinkgeld wie in deutschland
statt dem wort wie hat sie ja doch das
wort als benutzt wie und als sind zwei
worte die man im deutschen benutzt wenn
man vergleich gemacht und sie werden oft
verwechselt und das witzige ist sie
werden oft verwechselt von deutsch
lernen aber auch von muttersprachlern
manchmal deswegen reden wir heute
darüber
wandern was benutzt und was der
unterschied ist los geht's
grundsätzlich benutzt man als immer dann
wenn man einen vergleich macht und zwei
dinge unterschiedlich sind
new york ist größer als berlin
also wenn zwei dinge unterschiedlich
sind die man vergleicht benutzt man
immer als wenn man aber zum beispiel
sagt wien ist so groß wie hamburg dann
benutzt man wie denn wie benutzt man
immer dann wenn man zwei dinge
vergleicht die ungefähr gleich sind oder
genau gleich also als benutzt man immer
bei unterschieden und wie benutzt man
immer wenn dinge gleich sind jetzt haben
wir noch einen dritten fall und das ist
ein bisschen kompliziert aber auch nicht
so kompliziert
man kann einen satz haben der
ungleichheit ausdrückt aber eigentlich
redet er von gleichheit und in diesem
fall hat die junge dame gesagt man gibt
nicht so viel trinkgeld wie in den usa
die grundaussage des satzes ist so viel
wie und so viel wie ist eine
konstruktion die gleichheit ausdrückt
die die grundkonstruktion des satzes
drückt gleichheit aus man gibt in den
usa so viel trinkgeld wie in deutschland
sie hat aber diesen satz verneint sie
hat gesagt nicht
und dadurch wird eine gleichheit
verneint die aussage redet also von
etwas das unterschiedlich ist trotzdem
benutzt man hier wie weil die
satzkonstruktionen das erfordert wie
kann man sich also einfach merken wann
man als und wie benutzt als benutzt man
immer zum beispiel mit komparativen wenn
man eine komparativ form zum beispiel
größer kleiner mehr weniger länger höher
benutzt dann redet man immer von
ungleichheit im grammatischen sinne
also man sagt immer er hat mehr als er
ist größer als es ist länger als wenn
man jedoch etwas ausdrückt was gleich
ist und dazu gehört auch wenn man sagt
es ist so viel wie also diese
konstruktion sowie die wird immer mit
wie gebildet er ist so groß wie
mechanisch ist so groß wie karin hanisch
ist fast so groß wie kari die amish ist
nicht so groß wie carrie
unterschiedliche aussagen aber die
konstruktion ist gleich damit ihr euch
das ganze deshalb merken könnt haben wir
jetzt noch ein paar beispiele für euch
alex ist größer als ich alex ist so groß
wie ich mein kopf ist nicht so groß wie
der kopf von der statue
alex ist höher als carrie hallo ich
stehe genauso hoch wie alex diese blaue
tonne ist nicht so voll wie diese blaue
tonne diese tonne ist voller als diese
tonne dieses auto macht genauso viel
dreck wie dieses auto
[Musik]
dieses auto ist bunter als dieses auto
die 50 cent münze ist genauso groß wie
die vierte dollar münze zehn cent sind
nicht so groß wie fünf sind die fünf
cent münze ist größer als die zehn cent
münze die cocktails sind fast so teuer
wie das business land das geschäfts
mittagessen ist teurer als die cocktails
heute ist es kälter als morgen mittwoch
ist es genau so warm wie freitag
dieses haus ist schöner als dieses haus
dieser gehweg ist sauberer als diese
matratze dieser motor ist älter als
dieses motorrad dieser motorroller ist
das gleiche modell wie dieser
motorroller dieser motorroller hat eine
andere farbe als dieser mutterrolle
janosch hat mir street credibility als
carrie wenn ihr dieses thema jetzt noch
weiter üben möchte dann schaut doch mal
bei unserer app sie lenkt vorbei
schädling ist eine möglichkeit
interaktiv mit videos zu lernen
unter anderem könnt ihr dort eure eigene
aussprache aufnehmen und mit der
aussprache von muttersprachlern
vergleichen
ihr könnt auf die inter untertitel
draufklicken und grammatische
informationen erhalten und ihr könnt
auch übungen machen auch zu diesem thema
schaut mal vorbei auf sie länger dort
kommen und wir freuen uns sehr wenn wir
euch auch nächste woche wiedersehen
tschüs und bis bald